davon bekommt er in taschen geld von
5000 euro monatlich stopp an der stelle
stoppen habe es gerade gehört nur 5000
euro im monat eine frage leute kennt ihr
auch diesen schmerzhaften moment diesen
einsamen moment in dem man alleine in
seinem zimmer sitzt und sich denkt warum
ist das leben als teenager einfach so
geisteskrank scheiße
ich kenne auch leute aber noch mehr als
wir alle kennt ein junges mädchen mit
dem namen seiner frau ruth bader ein
business travel denn dieses mädchen
leuten muss und ich bitte euch jetzt an
eurem stuhl oder einem tisch
festzuhalten mit 5000 euro taschengeld
im monat auskommen und gegen diese
ungerechtigkeit werden wir heutige video
vorgehen ist doch dass davon hat geladen
zum wohl schrägsten job casting sattes
leihmütter gibt wenn die 18 jährige
wünscht sich ein baby unterzog da keine
lust dafür selbst so leute das ist schon
das ist schon wieder ist schon wieder
ein emotioneller tiefpunkt im leben von
safran
von diesem menschen der einfach einem
gewürz safran benannt wurde ja leute es
ist wirklich nicht leicht hat einer von
euch da draußen gedacht dass safran mit
bahn oder dieses mädchen was schon
allein der müsste mal drüber nach mit
5000 euro taschengeld im monat auskommen
musste sich ja wahnsinnig heute wissen
wir alle dass dieses mädchen dann auch
on top zu sowie die taschengeld noch
sein eigenes kind austrägt natürlich
nicht leute dafür um die sollte the way
leute dieses kind da dieser dieser
verwöhnte teenager 5000 euro sind zu
wenig leid taschengeld ist ist der täter
von diesem video 5000 euro sind zu wenig
taschengeld können wir zwar auf der
zunge zergehen lassen heute ja verdienen
die meisten menschen in ihrem leben
nicht mal brutto vor steuern im monat
aber okay ist wenn die taschengeld egal
was ich sage hat
falls ich jetzt mein gott ich will
unbedingt mit ihr mein leben tauschen
es ist so viel besser als ich ja es ist
auch das mädchen dem der freund geklaut
wurde vom eigenen vater also ihr vater
sie hat zwei schwule väter hat ihren
freund schwul gemacht der erfolg einfach
nicht nach leute
entweder christian dior oder tommy
hilfiger etwas anderes kam bei unseren
fünf kindern die in frage so oder so
leute so kümmert man sich um seine
kinder ganz essentiell wichtig für die
qualität und den nährstoffgehalt von dem
inhalt von babyfläschchen letztendlich
leute ist es welche marken name
draufsteht führende wissenschaftler sind
sich mittlerweile einig wenn man baby
milch von hipp einmal in ein gefäß von
christian dior ein viertel einmal ein
gefäß von kaufland oder enthält die
gleiche medium luxus becher
selbstverständlich deutlich mehr
mineralien aber ich muss noch mal sagen
was ich gesagt habe
sie sieht einfach aus wie ein angry bird
ich will wirklich ich will eigentlich
nicht so der oberflächliche seine leute
aber ich muss mal dass teufels advokat
pc spielen sie sieht aus wie ein angry
bird wie der gelbe engel blatt solche
kann man das bild habe ich mir jetzt
schon mal gesagt ich mache mache ich
kein problem so hier ist der gelbe engel
wird
ich wünsche mir so sehr an baby dann
kann ich es ihm die sonne karton packen
hat die sommer kinder wecken spazieren
fahren und habe eine echte miniatur von
real das ist auch der grund warum man
kinder kriegt leute kinder sind einfach
nur gehen wir sie nicht familie leute
sind wir ganz ehrlich kinder sind haben
wir für welchen zweck erfüllen sie
letzten endes einfach den ein spielzeug
für erwachsene zu sein ja so
funktioniert dass erwachsene denken sich
strikt an meinem auto lagen hat nicht
mein motorrad lang hat mich mein boot
langweilt mich
ich mach jetzt ein menschen spielzeug
mache ich einfach mal das kann ich dann
lustig anziehen das sieht aus wie immer
willkommen and surf stick hat braucht
sie das von geburt an wird sie mit luxus
überschüttet sieht das auch das sind ja
genau wie verehrt oder erstmal gibt es
gerade schon sagen also weil ganz
ehrlich wer diese transformation schon
durch macht in seinem leben wie sie hier
was weiß ich dass da ist viel möglich
zwei schwerst reiche homosexuelle
unternehmer die ihre fünf kinder
allesamt von leihmüttern austragen
ließen so wie es nun plant also ganz
ehrlich leute wenn wir wirklich mal die
hand aufs herz legen ist dieses leben
einfach eine komplette karikatur was ist
also das ist geisteskrank absurd das ist
auch nicht erstrebenswert also ich würde
auf gar keinen fall mit ihr jetzt
tauschen wollen never ever also bei
einerseits klar kann ich jederzeit
meinen vater anrufen und kann ihnen
sagen dass jetzt ein porsche haben wir
der kauf mit einem porsche
andererseits hat der gleiche vater der
einfach als freundlicher und du bist in
deinem kopf an einem so schlechten ort
dass du denkst 5000 euro sind zu wenig
taschengeld also ich habe wirklich
mitleid mit ihrer passiven bekommt ein
taschengeld von 5000 euro monatlich
stopp stopp an der stelle stoppen stadt
gehört nur 5000 euro im monat
wie soll sich denn davon lernen mit geld
umzugehen damit darf sie sich kaufen was
immer sie braucht oder möchte und was
soll sich damit kaufen das reicht ja
nicht mal findet das reicht ja nicht mal
für keine ahnung sind gerade mal sechs
rolex pro jahr
vorher muss eine pro woche kaufen würde
ihre anderen ausgaben sind damit nicht
abgedeckt wenn sie sich also neue
sneaker oder schuhe kaufen möchte einen
pulli oder eine jacke dann hat sie ja
noch ihre platin kreditkarte okay okay
immerhin immerhin da hat auch whatsapp
gerade dazwischengefunkt muss ich mal zu
machen
okay okay okay leute muss ein stück weit
zurücknehmen die 5000 euro sind also nur
für starbucks also 5000 euro für kaffee
im monat ist aber immer noch ein
hungerlohn
das geht überhaupt nicht ihre
schmucksammlung über eine million wert
allein diese zwei ringe
400.000 euro ok lacht in broock so also
jetzt mal hand aufs herz natürlich bei
weitem nicht so ich kann mich wirklich
nicht beschweren eigentlich aber der
gesetz soll auch da muss ich wieder
sagen gehabt jederzeit tausche ich gerne
mein normales relativ normales deutsches
leben wo es mir auch schon gut geht
tausche ich sehr gerne mit einem
englischen leben wo man zwei millionen
schmuck hat aber einfach dein freund von
einem fucking vaters geblitzt wird dann
wieder doch die schwangerschaftsstreifen
und all das also ganz ehrlich also hält
man also wir müssen auch sagen
einerseits klar in diesem beitrag ist
alles so dargestellt dass man sich als
zuschauer denkt so hart diese
superreichen degradierten dachschaden
man muss aber auch sagen haben sie auch
zum gewissen teil ist auch übertrieben
was wie es dargestellt wird zum gewissen
teil haben sie aber auch ein dachschaden
weil also sorry gehört das nicht so zu
erfahrungen dazu dass man so wenn man
ein kind bekommt auch ein bisschen
struggled so hat man das kind nicht noch
mehr liebt als ich höchstwahrscheinlich
in meinem leben liegen kind selbst
bekommen weil man aber ihr mädels da
draußen diese videos sehen würdet ihr
jemals in erwägung ziehen auch wenn ihr
stinkreich wert eine leihmutterschaft zu
machen
ich habe schon aussagen die die 18
jährige wohl einmal mehr zu einem der
verhasstesten rich kids der welt machen
dürften ihre regelmäßigen luxus shopping
exzesse sorgen bereits seit jahren für
kritik leute selbst selbst hat übrigens
schlechte leben
safe ganz ehrlich wenn es schon videos
auf youtube und die haben wirklich
millionen von klicks diese wie die haspa
sie so als arrogantes verzogenes belag
dargestellt wird 1000 richtiges leben
und alle mobben die payback ich mit euch
haye ist sebastians zukunft ist nike das
video und ich sehe das so was die so
sagen und denken also der ja eigentlich
tut mir dieses mädchen wirklich leid
sorry wenn ich zu hart zu der die typen
ich vielleicht ein bisschen fehlt also
nur noch die patente leihmutter die dann
das wunschkind der 18-jährigen austrägt
sagte 150000 euro winken
naja was was für eine kranke welt ist
das denn leute also teilweise ich muss
sagen ich bin gar nicht so ein riesiger
feind von dem kapitalismus also der
gesellschaftsordnung in der wir leben ja
aber so was also dass er wirklich
geisteskranke ja du lässt einfach jemand
ein kind was nicht da ist und nie die 1
sein wird im dich reinsetzen und lässt
sich dafür 150.000 euro geben jetzt sagt
mir einer von euch da draußen dass das
nicht geisteskrank es wenn man es fürs
geld macht wenn man aus irgendeinem
grund sich denken leihmutterschaft
budapester leben ich trage das kind
gerne ausland ist es weg wenn man da
irgendwie drauf mentalität meint also
wenn es einem gefällt klar okay sagt ich
mache das nur fürs geld das das geht
wirklich zu weit in meinen augen kann
jeder für sich selbst entscheiden aber
ich fand das ganz krank bist du bist
immer noch im wohnzimmer so
diese sagt mang steht aber so zwei meter
dahinter
marie leute die tut mir wirklich leid
und beide way eine sache aber ich noch
eine sache sagen warum sie mir noch mehr
leute ihre eltern haben sich scheinbar
dieses geisteskranker vermögen etliche
millionen selbst aufgebaut wisst ihr was
man dafür machen muss extrem viel arbeit
ein bisschen was man dann nicht mehr hat
zeit für seine kinder also wurde sie
wahrscheinlich auch als kind
vernachlässigt aber weniger weißt was
ich weiß drauf hauptsache 5000 euro
taschengeld
die auch noch zu wenig sind der schreibt
eure meinung dazu gerne in die
kommentare leute ihr wisst was ihr hier
drinnen machen können gibt alles für
euch hier ich bin der stelle raus ich
hoffe ihr da draußen ist nicht mit 5000
euro taschengeld auskommen sondern habt
eltern die milliardäre sind und nicht
lächerliche multimillionäre macht's gut